his president Trump's personal attorney
former New York City Mayor Rudy Giuliani
let me start with Muller how how is this
case impacted because struck is at the
heart of all of it heating claims I mean
he's played a much bigger role in this
and then a lot of the media wants to
admit but first of all he was there at
the very beginning he wrote all the
initial documents justifying this
investigation he ranted for 11 months he
conducted the critical interview of
Flynn with the very strange situation
where Flynn pled guilty to a to a lie
that the FBI said he didn't he didn't he
wasn't guilty of go figure that out he's
the one who was carrying the dossier and
using the dossier to justify the Pfizer
wires that has to be all unraveled
there's no doubt that there's therefore
false affidavits filed with the Pfizer
Krotz fraud lying in an affidavit to the
FISA Court the guy responsible for those
was largely struck he gathered the
evidence non evidence the dossier is
absurd I braided gold documents
ridiculous assertion dockets provably
false things like Cohen was in Prague it
wasn't abroad it says that there were
real estate deals with the Russians
there was no real estate deals with the
Russians it has trunkful question the
bed was my fee was with her I mean he
they have evidence he was headed he was
with hookers in a bet the bumped yeah
the bump completely de bump got the
dates all wrong it's it's a it's a
cut-and-paste job by a down-and-out
ex-spy English spy who hated Trump mr.
mayor don't lie to the American people
to end lie to the Clement and and the
the Justice Department the Trump Justice
Department is hiding those affidavits on
the grounds that the affidavits contain
national security information well my
goodness here are the things we need to
know about it was the fact that Hillary
Clinton and the DNC the the people who
pays us does that point it out to the
judge right because if it wasn't you got
a glaring
omission wasn't pointed out the steal
during the course of this was fired by
the FBI where his problems in his
background
exposed to the judge I mean when you
present this guy whether you presented
as a fully reliable informant well were
the questions but you have to do that in
NAFA David I brought many of these
anybody told the court in these
applications that Hillary paid for it
they purposely withheld that information
what a minute then that would have been
an OnStar but they never verified any of
the information so here's the point
struck created a false document when we
say is there any evidence that his bias
led to action that he took against Trump
yeah he perjured himself David in order
to start his insurance policy
investigation they were hoping they
could do something with that before the
election but they ran into the same
problem all runs into President do
anything wrong they couldn't find any
evidence they struck out on a couple
days before it wasn't he was inaugurated
they had to proclaim there was no
evidence of collusion which is not a
crime anyway is there any update since
you were on with us last and that is
that you responded to Muller in terms of
any potential that there'll be a
discussion with the president no they
think they have all the time in the
world I guess I don't know well I think
that we are we are running into a real
big problem for them if they try to drag
this thing much into September you've
got a very clear violation of the
Justice Department policy not to
interfere with elections Comey was just
excoriated by that for that by Horowitz
it'll just be another list of their
irregularities they're unethical
performance their unwillingness to
follow sensible rules they could have
done this we could have concluded this
and this this interview thing two months
ago and decided yes or no on it and
their report to be done by now there it
looks like this slowing the slowing down
you know they're running out the clock
the media would look at the 2005 tax
case that has nothing to do with Russia
nothing to do with the campaign nothing
to do with the President had a for tax
case from 2005 is the trial of the
century
okay well that's really portraying it
and but more seriously when we talk
about struck and call me and McCabe and
and page and and all these other people
in the FBI and the DOJ at the
it's levels do you see crimes oh
absolutely
I just told you one the perjury on the
affidavit I was telling you about
hillary crimes a year before
call me outline them all she get off
scot-free and all this i should got off
go through the fixed investigation of it
totally phony fixed indict and run by
Peter struck who then turns around the
dossier is is is obtained on the day
that they dropped the case against Trump
against Hillary so that case gets
dropped and have that even up the school
next day and go after storm the next day
now the reality is I'm gonna tell you
and we're not the time to go into and
what we can do later I'm gonna tell you
who orcas Ted was a quarterback for all
this it just struck he's a bit of a
puppet then there's mala he's a puppet
people working for him are some of them
are really funny feel you're about to
drop a bomb on me go ahead guy running
his brain and he should be in front of a
grand jury is Brendan Brendan CIA
director Brennan took a an affidavit a
dossier that I see it's the biggest
idiot intelligence agent that ever
existed although he never really did
much intelligence work it's false nickel
look at it and laugh at it and he
peddled it to Harry Reid meaning that
that led to the request for the
investigation so he takes a false
affidavit a false does yeah he gets the
Senators involved a couple Republican
senators and they demand an
investigation
totally phony investigation now why
can't we get an investigation when there
were clear facts showing possible
violations of the law even in the I
can't we even in the even in the order
appointing Muller which is completely
legitimate
they don't point out any crime you have
to point out a crime under the
Independent Counsel
regulations they don't point out we have
lots of crimes then we can't get we
can't get sessions to move and appointed
independent counsel he's he look I hate
the recused from it these were two for
everything
and Rosenstein it's too much involved in
him and they have possible witnesses
Rosen Stein signed the last FISA warrant
well that's why he's a possible witness
and possible anything else mr. mayor
griddle shape
thank you sir appreciate independent
counsel to investigate the investigators